thank you so much for doing this as you
know I absolutely love the boys
placement I I mean I love it so talk a
little bit about when you realized
because you were at Comic Con last year
and that's when you know people started
to see it but you never really know what
a reaction is going to be until people
actually start seeing it and then it
became this huge thing so when did you
realize that fans were really responding
to the material in the first inkling I
had that maybe we were on to something
was a you do these you know for the fans
out there watching I mean you know but
you do these press junkets where you're
in a hotel room and it's like frankly
like a gangbang of reporters or coming
in and it's like one after another and
you're and and you know you talked to
maybe thirty or forty reporters in one
day and we did that me and the cast and
the reporters had seen I believe like
the first three or four episodes and
seeing okay that was the first time I
had any audience you know outside of
just the people who worked on the show
and the genuine excitement like you can
tell you know like I can tell that like
you're you know you're excited about
these shows I've had other ones where
reporters are like couldn't give a [ __ ]
just waiting to get to you know the
actor they want to talk to or they or
you know the dead giveaway line is
always like tell me about the pranks on
set and that means like they don't know
your show they don't know who you are
maybe they have zero idea about any of
it and but this one people were coming
in we're like genuine excitement in
their eyes and we're asking like
passionate questions and and we're
telling us over and over again like how
did you you know how did you manage to
hit those I guys you know this this
completely and then you know I started
to feel this kind of growing excitement
although I think people are gonna get
this and
you know and then it's just when it
premieres you just it premieres you
immediately as much as your runners
pretend they don't I'm staring at tweets
and comments and I'm like obsessed
you know them they're all day reading
and only remembering the bad ones and
and and but there just seemed like the
response was really great and then
Amazon it's just funny it's like all
these streaming sites they won't tell
you their metrics like when I was at NBC
you know I would you know revolution or
something like I got a call the next
morning you know and someone said oh my
god we have 12 million viewers and
that's amazing and on this like they
just no streaming say it releases their
internal data then you have like 220
people watching this show do 20 million
people watch the show like I literally
to this day have no idea so you can only
gauge it by how happy they are when they
wink at you that's literally how I know
if the show works like it's you know
I'll see Jen and Vernon and they'll be
like it's going good and you know great
that seems like it's going good and and
it was that was what it was which is
they they reached out you know week or
two in and they are like well we are in
good shape and I'm like great it seems
like it's working but I but again I
can't even tell you what that number
means cuz I don't and me and Neil Moretz
when the producers he's and literally
every single phone call he's just like
great great good good meeting good
creative meeting so how many people are
watching the show I was gonna say you
knew that they believed in it because
you guys got a season two picked up
before the first season aired yeah so
yeah no no they were there they're
really happy creatively and you can also
see a audience test everything not
surprisingly Amazon's a very data driven
company and you know there's deep the
testing on every single thing and our
testing was through the roof and then
you know that was a good show of
confidence for season two
so ya know they've been and the event by
the way the marketing muscle they put
behind the show was insane it was the
best of my career I'm so used to
fighting the marketing people the
squeeze you know more money out of them
and more attention and this time I just
was like oh okay great
wow you're spending that much that's
crazy
so it was they they are behind the show
in a big way and I you know I really
appreciate it
I'm curious when you look back on the
first season what was you obviously had
no matter how much time you have no
matter how much budget you had you're
always gonna hit that wall so what were
the things that you remember you know
being challenges with the time and money
you had the first one that pops into my
head funny enough is the dolphin
sequence because the original scripted
version believe it or not as crazy as
that scene was it was much more
elaborate in the original script like it
involved it was much more of like a
heist you know like in the show you just
see the van kind of smashing out of
ocean land and but in the original
version like deep snuck in he hopped the
fence he went to the pool the dolphin
came out he was talking back and forth
to the dolphin you know he had a ramp he
got the dolphin out of the water like it
was like that hiding from cameras
sneaking the dolphin out it was much
more like a robbery
you know sequence and and it was just so
prohibitively expensive we were trying
we were talking about like okay do we
train a dolphin to do that can we get
our robot dolphin in the water he was
all these conversations and it was just
way beyond our budget so but that's what
I mean I think that's the value of
having you know a little bit of
experience as a TV producer is me and
Craig Rosenberg who wrote it here's a
genius we just looked at it and just
when you're in TV you're scrappy and you
go like okay what's important here and
and Craig said well what's important is
a dolphin
through a windshield and I was like
wreck so let's just let's pick it up
let's pick it up there and and then what
became a really impossible sequence
suddenly became you know manageable
still with a robot dolphin but whatever
it was it was manageable one of the
things I think one of things I responded
to and I think the reason why so many
people loved the show is that every
episode has something funny there's
action but mostly you never know what
the f is gonna happen in the next scene
there's okies that like you know the
unexpectedness of the show how much in
the writing process
are you guys like coming up with your
arc of the episode and then sort of
peppering in these curveballs that no
one sees coming how much are the
curveballs being thought of you know
what I mean in the genesis of it um I
would say really specifically actually
there's two things we talk about a lot
in the room very consciously cuz you
know we know what the tone of the show
is and and what we want to hit so we
definitely have conversations every
episode of like okay what's you know one
or two really insane things to happen in
this episode and we specifically go for
those like you know we had just as an
example of season 1 episode 6 whose
episode 6 where we just were like
they're just not crazy enough there's
nothing in here that is really markedly
nuts you know and and Craig Rosenberg
who you know the pattern of this
interview is like what a freaky is it
was Craig Rosenberg who pitched and the
girl you know fingering deep skills and
that was very late I mean we had already
written I think a network draft before
that scene even existed because we were
just looking for how do we how do we
blow people's minds in this one and now
seeing a lot of that I might argue we
overshot the mark but and then and then
in terms of like character stuff which
is frankly the more important stuff I
mean
you know that that's the the shocking
stuff is frosting and and the real stuff
is you give a [ __ ] about the characters
and are the characters having depth and
on that one we work really really hard
to make sure that where they land or
where they go is the opposite of where
you expect them to be we play that game
in the room all the time like the note
I'll give isn't as much as any other
note in the writers room is ya know I'm
sorry that story doesn't work because I
know that it's going there I'm ahead of
you and I am that's where it seems like
it's going so let's play the game of
opposites what would be the most
shocking thing to happen in that moment
and the complete opposite of what you
think and then they'll pitch the
diametrically opposed opposite of what
they just pitched and I was like ok
that's cool how do we get to that and so
we talk I'm you know structure have
every writer every has their own thing I
love structure you know it's like the
OCD and me I just love the building of
the shape and how you can misdirect like
a magic trick and and so to me like just
making sure the structure always turns
and no way you're not expecting is
something that you know I think really
works in this show one of the other
things I really love is that none of the
characters are black or white you know
they're everyone is gray so how much did
you think about in the writing process
early on how much did you know that that
was the way it was going to be and you
know figuring out the arc of the entire
season how early on did you figure you
know what I mean that that figuring out
where it's ultimately gonna go in that
first season yeah um you know in terms
of like the characters I mean I would
say even just looking at my my work I
tend I'm very bad at writing straight
villains I don't know how to frankly I
know I honestly just don't know how to
do it I don't know how anyone can look
themselves in the mirror in the morning
and say like today I'm gonna do a whole
[ __ ] ton of evil like I just don't it
makes no sense to me I mean and if you
look at my work you look at like you
know I spent a lot of time humanizing
Lucifer ice cream you know expeller and
supernatural I you know all my villains
always
seem to turn out to be allies of the
heroes by if you look at revolution
timeless and and and it's just because I
can't help but try to you know a writing
mantra that I really live by as
everyone's the hero of their own story
and so I really spend a lot of time with
the you know I don't even really I'd say
antagonist way more than I say villain
you know and I spend a lot of time with
the antagonists and like okay why are
they doing so what I mean even though
their motivation might be psychotic in
home Landers case totally sociopathic
but at least I need to understand why
he's doing it you know and and so just
even applying just my writing style but
to to the boys brought us there but um
but you know the other thing is a really
really talented staff and we all just
approached it in you know the the
guiding compass was what if superheroes
were real and not just hey not just as a
catchphrase like a stringent discipline
that every single possible decision we
could what's the most possible the most
realistic you know version of that
moment or that character be possible and
so it it forced you to make characters
that have a lot of shades of gray
because it forces you into conversations
of like wow what would it be like to be
a speedster but you're not the only one
and you're trying to hold on to your
number one slot and like that would
stress the [ __ ] out of you like you're
always looking for you know young guns
trying to try to you know knock you off
your perch and so it's just those
conversations you know or if you if the
only thing you could do is talk to fish
how ultimately insecure you would be and
how that would make you laugh out in all
of these totally inappropriate ways
because you know you're you're a [ __ ]
joke and you know it and so it's just
those conversations create character
rather than you know sort of broad you
know cartoonish villains I'm sure people
who are fans of the show want to know
and actually forget the fan
I really want to know when you're
sitting down to work out the first
season how much are you thinking okay if
this shows a hit how do i how far are
you thinking about the overarching
storyline beyond the first season how
much does the network Amazon want to
know okay
this all sounds great but tell me your
five-year plan you know it's a I mean
it's not dissimilar from I mean there
were sort of that you know this idea in
Supernatural that I had this kind of
incredibly fleshed out five-year plan I
think got a little exaggerated with the
fans then from what I originally it at
least said or intended to say a which
was like it was a napkin sketch it's a
it's a it's a it's a map you know I we
you know I someone said this one it
wasn't me but like you know show arcs or
of map like if you it's the United
States and you're starting in LA and you
know you want to go through Chicago and
you'll want to end up in you but how we
get there and what the route is I have
no idea and that's all this is and
that's all that was I mean I certainly
write you know I certainly write for
success
anyone who's seen my other shows know
the crazy cliffhangers
I ended them on when we got canceled
good I just don't it doesn't occur to me
I'm not somebody who writes you don't
write to lose your right to win and so I
definitely knew that heading I wanted a
huge cliffhanger in season one I wanted
it to totally change the story in season
two
you know I have a notion of what's
tracking and and what's you know that
the two major forces and of the boys
mostly homeland er but home liner in the
seven how are these two you know forces
moving forward and heading ultimately to
an ultimate conflict and I mean I have
that in my mind but I couldn't tell you
like what are the scenes that get us
there it's just I kind of know what a
couple of the set pieces I want once
we're you know hopefully in season five
when you make
the first season I believe you had four
months of principal photography and when
I was doing some research it seemed like
season two at five months of seat of
principal photography so that's an extra
month oh you don't mean if I'm not
mistaken
that's a lot of time to add to a to to
build these episodes so what did that
extra month of filming get you in
comparison to the first season um there
was a to Amazon and Sony's credit you
know they had an appetite for to see a
bigger scope of the show in season two
you know they felt like you know I mean
which I understand like when you're in
this kind of premium television space
and you're competing such as a genre
show and you're competing against these
huge shows you know you have to be able
to walk the walk in terms of it's it's a
show that has you know some some epic
style to it and I said absolutely
totally it's I mean the funny thing
about filmmaking is like none of it is
rocket science it's just time and money
like you can you can figure out anything
with with good smart people around you
that are smarter than you time and money
and so I think the extra month was
mostly we moved the shooting schedule
from nine days to twelve days by the way
for people that don't realize that's a
lot of time yeah yeah no it's good I
mean it's by the way it's never enough
but it's it's good yeah like
supernatural shoots for eight days so to
be able to shoot for twelve is is a
luxury still wasn't nearly enough but um
but so yeah so and then you know they
they goofed up our budget you know a bit
and you know that time buys you the
ability and by the way it doesn't just
mean like big huge action scenes it does
mean some of those but you know I was
really adamant because you know I've
been around the block once or twice and
and you know a lot of show runners make
a mistake of like looking at their
second season and decide
like okay I'm gonna top it I'm gonna top
season one and that's a mistake because
that you can't sustain that because
season three can't top see you know even
if you try season three to top season 2
and season 4 to top season 3 like
eventually you'll just you'll this why
most shows or a lot of shows kind of
explode and you're just like oh that
jumped the shark because they were
trying too hard so for me you know
season 2 of the show didn't have to go
bigger it had to go deeper so it was
always that it was like what tell me
what can I learn about these characters
that make that explain why they are the
way they are how do we put we literally
played the game and we went through each
character and we said how do we put them
through that specific character what
would be the most painful thing for that
person specifically to go through and
can we put them through that this season
or how do we take away the one thing
that they need the most you know we just
played that game of how do you torture
them Sam Raimi told me once he's like
you know what a filmmaking is he's like
it's creating characters you love them
and torturing them and I actually come
back to that all the time he's not wrong
no no he's exactly exactly I mean that's
why I had Sam Raimi Oh Sam Raimi so ya
know so so a lot of the time went to yes
we have some huge sequences there's
larger sea mammals you know there's like
there's some bigger stuff for sure but
there's also a lot more intense stuff
and there's scenes that were really
difficult for the actors emotionally and
require a little bit more time and and
so it's not just always like the visuals
that are epic I think the emotions are a
little more epic this season and you
know and that just takes TLC with the
actors working it through giving them
time to do their thing you know one
thing I love about this show and will
always want to protect that you know
unlike most in the superhero genre this
is a character first story and that goes
to on set like our first priority is
always making sure the actors have the
tools they need
the most complicated performance as they
can and then we worry about the visual
effects and all that [ __ ] for season two
can you share anyone who's directing
sure we have Phil secretion we have Alex
graves Sarah Boyd Fred toy is back
Stefan Schwartz is back and a great
young director named aboutin Silva oh
did you tell many episodes I did not
direct this year for the simple reason
that we had some had some parenting I
had to do at home and so couldn't
couldn't go up for it hypothetically if
I knew that you guys were doing a season
three I would say it right now and say I
think fans can look forward to a season
three even if you won't say it so I'll
ask you this question you always have to
be ahead of where production is and
obviously this pandemic has allowed you
guys you know basically I'm assuming
that there's a writers room churning out
ideas for season three right now even if
you're not filming even if the show
wasn't been picked up I'm sure the
network is thinking about that you know
like I can neither confirm nor deny
anything that's happening regarding
season three got it I'll move on to the
next thing
season two eight episodes and did you
ever think about doing like nine or ten
episodes oh no God no I I would do less
if they'd let me
you like you like the you know the
tighter the the less hours you have to
fill the tighter your story can be
completely so do you think that so for
you guys eight episodes is like the key
but that's the thing you want to hit yes
or is season two or all the episodes the
same length or any supersized um they're
roughly the same length I mean they all
kind of vary between like 55 and 65
minutes but we do have a couple that are
I think like 64 or 65 minutes fantastic
yeah what can you tease about the new
characters in season 2 the most primary
new character
is this character Stormfront who's a new
hero played by aya cash is so brilliant
and you know she really comes in and she
shakes up the seven she we wanted to
bring in a character who really not
homeland her on his heels in a way that
no character really has been able to yet
and so that was really fun and she
really shakes it up and she has a lot of
layers and we have some reveals mm-hmm
but um you know she turns out to when we
finally reveal who she is she turns out
to be a real real problem and I cannot
[ __ ] wait uh can you compare how can
you bear the blood and guts of season
two to season one
there's probably it's funny there's
probably more I guess
had you asked me a couple of weeks ago
I'd have said oh you know I think it's a
it's it's a more character-driven season
but now that I've shown it to people
everyone's like oh my god it's so much
bloodier and you must be numb to how
bloody the show is at this point because
it's so much gnarlier and there's so
many more guts I'm like are there I just
kept thinking that this was a this
season was the my dinner with Andre
season I guess but yeah so I think
there's gonna be more where are you in
post-production have you finished
everything for the eight episodes I
literally finished today really yeah I
will finish this afternoon yeah that I'm
sure you are over the moon
yeah no it's nice it's been a long long
journey so yeah it's exciting to cross
the finish line I'm sure the actors gave
you a lot of notes about their costumes
no one enjoys acting in those costumes
how did you incorporate what they had to
say about the costumes in terms of
redesigns or costume adjustments for
season two it's all just a process and
there's time our costume our super suit
designer LJ Shannon who's a genius and
has done a bunch of these she it's all
her I mean she's amazing with the actors
and they have such an open flow of
communication that they just may pick up
the phone and they call her and she's
it's working on ways to make it you know
a little more comfortable for them and
they give notes along or thoughts along
the process but um she's so good and
responsive that a lot of times I don't
even know they just show me something
awesome and and I give a couple thoughts
but otherwise I'm in love with it so now
that that part of the the company is
almost its own self running machine what
can you tease about Giancarlo's were all
in season two just that he plays so much
you know we really expand his role you
know we really you know with Lisa shoe
GaN we really needed a character to kind
of represent you know be the face of
this of the true frankly the true
monster of this show which is bought and
and he does that with his icy chilling
demeanor and you know I've loved him
ever since I worked with him on
revolution he's just one of my favorite
actors and I was just I was just
thrilled mah nerd that you know he was
open to coming back and playing again
yeah I he's always so awesome and
whatever he does um Jeffrey Dean Morgan
has expressed interest in being on the
show in season 3 um have you have you
taken his desire to be on the show to
heart I absolutely have there's one role
we're already talking about you know he
has to we have to figure it we have to
like coordinate because you know he's on
he's on The Walking Dead
so he has he has another home but we
already talked about one role and there
might be a potential other that we're
talking about but like we we are just
this past week we were literally texting
back and forth about trying to figure
out how to get him on the show so I
don't think it's a done deal yet but the
will is there and we're both talking
about yeah is it one of those things
where he really just wants to play any
role are you trying to think about
something badass I mean I I thought
about a role for him that we're talking
about but I'm you know but but you know
we're just still it's really embryonic
as I said in all the season 3 stuff is
very I'm
so there's room for us to just you know
figure something out I loved the video
you guys released forget when the little
homeland or one where it shows him you
know as a teenager or you as a kid yeah
yeah do you do you yeah kid do you have
more of that kind of stuff coming um
well there were plans for it I'm not
sure what the latest is in this in this
plague time you know a lot of it I think
is getting scrapped but we're trying to
I think we're trying to get one or two
things going but it's hard because you
know production is everything's mostly
halted and so just figuring out how to
get it shot right now is the challenge
yeah completely
when you look on season 1 one of the
things I like about the streaming
services is it seems like you could
offer a lot more extras than sometimes
are currently available did you end up
having a lot of deleted scenes or things
that have not been seen that you think
would be good for the fans to see that
you know could be added for extras or is
it sort of like you know that's not a
thing that really comes up we know I
mean I think you know the Amazon x-ray
department which is sort of like their
equivalent of DVD special features we're
have been amazing and they're the ones
who you know created that spot with the
homeland er kid V and we really put up
all of our season 1 scenes that are of
note you know there's trims there's like
shots of a guy walking into a bar but
I'm not gonna put those up but but any
real scene and and and a bunch of great
extras are really up on that x-ray site
but in and we're doing we're certainly
putting all the good deleted scenes in
season 2 oh that reminds me actually we
had a scene we are going to release like
a pretty substantial thing because we
had a whole storyline in episode 2 where
it's not really spoiling anything to say
that in season two begins butcher is
kind of
a-and and then and then shows up and in
Episode two we originally had shot
something that really revealed you know
where he went and what his experiences
were but it ultimately didn't end up
fitting that well into the episode
because it made butcher story you know a
lot less mysterious and intriguing and
it kind of slowed down the rhythm a
little bit it was better to not know in
that particular episode but we had these
scenes and so we strung them together
into a short film called butcher and
we're gonna release that which is you'll
be able to see it as this as the short
film of like what is a blank you know
missing you know a couple weeks looked
like and it'll work as a companion piece
to the show there's actually references
in the show that you won't understand
unless you see this thing because it was
it was really tied in to our plot so
that battle come out that'll be cool do
you have is the end is the plan to
release that between Episode one in
Episode two or something where like
you're gonna release it much sooner it
won't be released before this series
comes out but sometime in the middle of
the release of the series it'll it'll
come out I'm basically out of time with
you I'm trying to think about any last
little thing but um one of the things I
guess want to ask about the VFX because
I mean what you guys accomplished in the
first season I think what a lot of
people won't realize is in the episode
where a Hugh's girlfriend oh yeah yeah
yeah Robyn yeah when all that blood was
all CGI you know from what I understand
which to me is just jaw-dropping that I
think people don't realize that was not
on set that was all you managed to weave
that with practical shooting with the
effects and I'm curious if you could
talk a little bit about what VFX it you
know how that amplifies what you're able
to do and maybe what you learned making
the first season with the VFX that
you'll be able to or you did with the
second season yeah I mean
you know the I'm in love with our VFX
and and it's almost entirely due to
stuff in the fleet who is our you know
VFX supervisor he's just basically like
the quote-unquote director of the visual
effects and he oversees the all the
different you know visual effects houses
that are doing the effects and he gives
creative notes and then he'll show them
to us we'll give him notes and and we'll
go on but like um he is a genius he
actually for timeless fans I met him on
timeless and then you know brought him
he did the pilot and then he did season
two and now I just refused to let him go
because he's the best I've ever worked
with and like I won't let him go
anywhere else and he so you know I mean
we I think well I think what we learned
frankly in season one it's not usually
the lesson you learn which is but we
could probably push it further because
we had the talent to pull it off you
know and supernatural for instance I
learned really quickly not to go for big
shots because we just didn't have the
money we have the talent but we just
didn't have the money to pull it off and
so rather than doing something huge and
falling on your ass we tended to you
know be smart about what we could
accomplish that's why somewhere in the
middle of season 1 of Supernatural
suddenly all the monsters just started
to look like humans but with different
colored eyes and but on this show like
you know it takes a lot of time and
sweat and blood and any single given
shot we probably did minimum of 80
versions of and I think there was
thousands of shots you know so it's just
it takes me and Stefan and the directors
being just so you know going through it
literally pixel by pixel and and it just
takes effort just takes time but I think
what we learned was you know he pulled
it off so beautifully and and I thought
everything looked you know really
feature quality even on our budget which
is not a feature budget
the lesson we learned was like well
let's see if we can push this further so
we did we have a I think we have a
season 2 with more ambitious visual
effects and I think he pulled those off
too I know I think for the first time he
started to sweat for the first time I
like you could catch like a little bit
of a fear in his voice
buddy buddy pulled it up for everyone
watching right now who has not seen the
boys which is probably nobody but if you
haven't seen the boys for the love of
[ __ ] God watch the boys
it is it's just fantastic thanks for
spreading the word about the show yeah
we really love it so we're I'm always
excited to talk to somebody loves it too